produced and financed in collaboration
with social point games how's it going
Prince this is big what if ranked gotcha
you want to hold a baby that's too bad
aren't you I'm sorry baby punch me baby
no more jokes we're here to play
hardcore games dragon Len we're gonna
play dragon land today this game Kim's
out this game come out today it's really
cool and we have a little surprise later
that's gonna be pretty good okay yes
that is the surprise it was supposed to
be later ha ha ha okay that's Maya you
can play as my end game I didn't know
either that was the most Awkward reveal
of a surprise
oh she's got that booty though you have
to use the wall climb with my aunt ah
just like she does at home to climb up
the bed it really does look like Maya
except my ass two eyes she's been
reincarnated okay you're right is that
younger she raising Edgar
okay now Maya's gonna fly oh my god girl
Maya you can do it come on my double job
she's doing oh how many times are you
gonna kill her dog
Oh Oh gotta wait longer than that wait
what
I died yeah let me oh why do you think
you know better than me I look first try
first right all right first right
why did I die first huh huh second try
hey I changed my mind oh shoot try not
to swing you did it mighty good job
Wow wow you're so good at games just
don't die cuz like are you okay you did
it
Bravo yeah I ever write positive
comments tomorrow yeah
you're so good mice yeah I can't I try
my day where is it gay where is it where
is it
hmm do you know who daddy me but I think
I look kind of cute well what well what
if you look at blizzy
that's cute and if you like it me it's
Helen what went wrong I'm like you
Dragon say it now say I'm a cute dragon
I'm I'm gonna play as mean best player
in this game hard yeah I play hard
anymore
thank playing hard you probably were
playing super easy
oh man look good this dragon is oh I can
fly I'm a dragon finally look at me
she's way too fat you know
well Martine pitter-pat be able to get
past the wall you didn't even wait for
it yeah oh my gosh I didn't done it
you did it the banana has serious powers
Wow
hey I play I did it yeah right positive
comments I mean only me oh man
so now we have blaze you don't remember
blaze from our videos back in the day
when we would you don't remember blaze
I'm really offended you know you to
forget about blaze hey blaze is my
favorite blaze whoa this is cool level
do you watch a movie with a dragon and
the dragon horn yeah dragon toy is that
I thought that was so freaky when he
takes out his heart I'm like awesome
we've warned up okay I think now it's
time to challenge each other in this
game let's see here let's go what we got
the brush we got the bro are you playing
online okay all right Alvaro Halle Mara
and my Madrid Madrid yeah all right all
right you come on
Spain you're going down yeah other
people oh my god what do we do just run
just run just run you got to win you got
it yeah - get a good start you got a
bomb I'm gonna use it for you nice we
bombed them
you keep pooping out bomb for some
reason come on don't forget to buy the
wall run yet the tornado yeah how is he
faster than us kill him look it took its
super shortcut lose bomb what are you
doing okay oh god you got hit by
lightning this spike ball oh we can we
who your turbo go go go
ah no I quit yeah come on I can stop you
already one you ruined my gaming rep
this is my this is my avatar hey that's
right Erol grass that's right Alfonso
fire kuhar get on our level that was fun
I want to do that again alright ok we go
alright this is PewDiePie the Pro versus
miss dragon nice oh god they're level 27
we're maxed that level because the
developers gave us the best character
thank you run like the wind Paige damn
it
oh I got fun hey this
no trying millions of levels of him then
don't worry about it
careful careful no I got this
no no shield yeah that's what I'm
talking about video games
I am the best player what's up
check out dragon lane it's out now
honestly it's really fun I really enjoy
the multiplayer yeah so you want to
check it out we'll leave a link to in
description check out my beautiful skin
and my as well and you can do that too I
am oyster eyes every day believe a lie
for you doing watching Thank You Marzia
for joining me and brofist stay awesome
press okay I don't die today
okay you can't see excuse you're short
that's your own fault
no I can fly hahahaha